Veamos unos ejemplos con exponentes fraccionarios.
Ya sabemos que si yo tomo por ejemplo,
9 a la potencia 1/2,
esto es igual a 3,
y sabemos eso por que 3 por 3 es igual a 9,
esto es equivalente a tomar la raíz cuadrada de 9,
eso es igual a 3, pero,
¿qué pasaría si por ejemplo yo tomo 9 a la -1/2?
¡Ay! Como que dices ¿qué onda, qué hago ahí? ¿no?
Me da miedo, pero no te intimides simplemente respira hondo y date cuenta de ese signo negativo...
primero... primero que todo,
ignora la fracción
y ahí tenemos un signo negativo
que lo convierte en un exponente negativo,
entonces, esto simplemente es lo mismo a
1 sobre 9 a la 1/2 ¡Fácil! ¿Cierto?
Ese signo negativo es lo que representa, 9 a la -1/2,
será igual a 1 sobre 9 a la 1/2,
pero 9 a la 1/2 es igual a 3, entonces tenemos como resultado final 1/3 y ya terminamos.
Vayamos ahora un poco lejos.
¿Ok? ¿A qué será igual esto?
Ponle pausa al vídeo, cuando ponga el ejemplo y...
e inténtalo entonces,
por ejemplo - 27 a la -1/3... a la -1/3
Se ve... se ve aterrador pero,
pero ponle pausa, inténtalo.
Y a qué será igual entonces, veamos.
Simplemente relájate, recuerda, relájate respira hondo
y deshazte del signo negativo.
Entonces esto será igual a 1
sobre -27 elevado a la 1/3 positivo,
y tal vez tú digas, bueno,
esto no me está haciendo la vida más sencilla,
porque tengo este -27 entonces...
¿Ok? Tranquilo no pasa nada,
cuándo tienes ese...
tienes aquí un número negativo
elevado a un exponente fraccionario,
pero eso simplemente te está diciendo
o te está pidiendo encontrar un número tal,
que si lo multiplicas 3 veces a él mismo,
te da el número - 27... igual a - 27,
¿qué número cumple con eso?
Ya sabemos que 3 a la tercera potencia...
3 a la tercera potencia es igual a 3 por 3, por 3,
y es igual a 27 eso, 27 positivo.
Entonces a -3 a la tercera potencia,
¿a qué será igual?
Esto es lo mismo que -3 multiplicado por -3 por -3
y -3 por -3 es igual a 9 positivo,
9 positivo por -3 es igual a -27,
y encontramos el número misterioso,
así que -3 por -3 por -3 es igual a -27,
por lo tanto -27 a la 1/3...
esta parte es igual a -3,
entonces, esto 1 sobre -27 a la 1/3,
es lo mismo que 1 sobre -3,
ó lo que es lo mismo -1/3.
Y ya, terminamos. Nos vemos.